du bist jung irgendwie konservativ und
Besitzer eines Penis dich nervt die
ganze voke Scheiße hier und Frauen die
alles dürfen was du darfst ganz genau
ganz genau dann mach jetzt den
ultimativen bad ass
[Musik]
15 Semester katholische Theologie ließ
Hebräisch Latein die Schriften von Tours
von mir mehr Hardcore geht nicht wir
machen dich zum Alpha Babo sagt mir mal
einen coolen Verein wo nur Bros die gute
tragen und die Chicks plus Schmücken des
Beiwerk sind ja okay die Hells Angels
aber sonst nur bei uns kriegt jeder
Bruder eine eigene Shisha wie geil ist
das denn schockier deine Eltern und wird
katholischer Priester kommt zum Altar
Alter gott will dass du cool wirst